so Adam welcome to my office thank you
sir that's on the internet this is
called the cosmic office so I have a
sample of aerogel really yes I have
never touched a simple really always
wanted to be a first for Adam Savage
okay aerogel is the most ghost-like
solid substance ever spun really yes and
it's used for NASA and the aerogel is a
has many applications but one of the
ones that we care most about is you put
that on a spacecraft on it on a space
probe and as it flies through a comet's
tail or particles of the comet enter the
gel and it slowly stops it so that it's
intact by the time you bring it back and
then analyze it so you among the many
things you can do with it
comet's tail it's also it's highly
insulating properties it's like the most
one of the most insulating things ever
known and the way they make it if they
have some polymer chain that they spin
up and it's this solid thing but then
they evaporate all the liquid and what's
left are the molecules that are that
that flesh out the volume that the
liquid once occupied and so and it's
like 99.9 percent air right yes higher
than that okay that is one of the
coolest things is like ghost it's
actually it's actually solid alright
it's not it's not flexible right it's
and it's very brittle it is science
cotton candy don't eat it Chuck okay
ready that is aerogel look at that
that's oh oh my god I can feel that it's
you can pick it up it's like a ghost
that is
oh that really is too cool man it might
be the lowest density solid stuff ever
because it's not I mean it's it's it's
it's volume filling strands of molecules
is this how neutrinos talk about earth
good tree no earth is like transparent
all right so that is great this is
aerogel and I have a whole cuba that is
an incredible collection of aerogel
so I am honored that I could show Adam
some he had never seen or touch before I
show you some you need even know existed
it so true it just might be we got we
got Adam here cuz he's got a new book
yes we would have him anyway even
without the book let's make that clear I
appreciate every tools a hammer life is
what you make it
I see what he did there yeah that's very
cool right right alright we're signing
off on Startalk Adam thanks for coming
to town awesome
you